so
for this next part
it's going to be easiest if you have
this piece of paper in front of you now
i know you've also got cards all over
your table my suggestion is i'm just
watching the time i would encourage you
to just pop your cards into one part
unless you're like no no i just finished
the trip don't mess with my cards okay
if that's the case maybe just use a bit
of other space for rest of you though
you can actually put them to one side
and then we're going to work through
this so that we can try and get the
important information down and i want to
see if i can explain this to you okay
so we're going to actually do this twice
and you'll see why we do it twice in a
minute it's actually very important we
do it twice this first method if you
want to fill it in you can see i've got
this um
i'm a big believer in spoiler free
worksheets i hate it when i go to the
movies and someone's like oh that's the
bad guy i'm like you just ah i hate when
people spoil movies that's why it's not
very descriptive we're gonna call method
one
numerical
because what we're gonna do is we're
just gonna start doing a bit of counting
of the numbers and see
what that will teach us okay
now you can see this table kind of has
four spots that you can put in
working we're just going to put some big
numbers there actually
piles one two three four i've kind of
numbered them in the order that they
appeared those ones down the bottom
which um which color do we have over
here on the left
these are the blacks okay so i'm just
going to say black and then i'm also
going to say
these are face up
and then over here on the other side
that's where we had the red cards
and they're also face up
okay
part three and part four
um they're kind of i'm actually just
going to put a question mark there
because the whole point is we actually
don't know what those are and we'll come
back to those shortly
all right
now hey sir did you want
jack for a couple of minutes is that
okay
okay
no worries okay now
no problem now before i um before i
start to write down numbers okay this is
a numerical approach you might recall we
had our four piles of cards when we
first performed the trick now i heard i
was listening as i wandered around as
you guys were doing this right i heard a
really good hypothesis a really good
like conjecture which was that there are
52 cards and originally we made four
piles
52 divided by 4
is 13. so a really good hypothesis or
conjecture is there might be 13 cards in
every one of the let me just put it back
there in every one of the four piles
it's a good idea
sometimes it's true
but often it's not and i'll show you how
i know this is the first time that i
perform the trick you can see here right
so i'm just going to count you may
actually remember this happening i don't
have 13 cards over here on the left hand
side i've got one two three four five
six seven eight nine
not close to 13 at all far fewer and you
may remember the reason why it's because
at a certain point like right near the
start i had this huge streak of red
cards and i was like i'm hoping i'll get
a black card eventually if anyone
noticed that so because i had a long
streak of red cards i just ended up with
more red cards over here you can see
it's many more than the nine black cards
i have on the other side now i said it
was a good idea it's a good hypothesis
you're like but mr will was wrong yes
but wrong ideas are very important to
pursue in mathematics because if you
don't pursue them you don't know which
ones are right okay so here's what i'm
going to do even though your numbers may
be slightly different to mine i invite
you to follow along with me that i now
know there are
nine oops i used the wrong one
nine black cards here
now remember i showed you all those red
cards that i had if i wanted to i could
just physically count them out
but i don't need to
we can use our mathematical glasses to
see that i can actually work this number
of red cards out without any counting at
all some of you can tell me how many
cards there should be over here on the
right hand side in my situation any
takers go ahead
17 come and write 17 with me and think
about why what was your name sorry
esha let's work out how isha knew like
she's not even anywhere near my cards
right where does the number 17 come from
any takers yeah go ahead 26
all right so
26 take away the 9 on the left gives you
17 but then that asks the next question
why 26 take away 9 what's the
significance of 26 jack because there
has to be 26 in each two rows okay
fantastic so every one you put down you
put another one down very good so these
are the face up cards here right in the
bottom half
every time you place the card down the
bottom here you paired it or you matched
it with a card up here so one up one
down
two up two down eventually once you
finish the whole deck it'll be
26 down to 26 we counted
and 26 uh up on both sides make sense
all right i promised that we would
return up to these mystery cards up here
now the thing is there's actually kind
of two piles in each pile right because
some of them are black
some of them are red now we already know
because we counted them when i first
performed the trick that there are
i think was five was it five
black cards over here right
now we could then go over to the end i
said oh look i hope there are five red
cards over here which was a bit
facetious of me i already knew there
were going to be five red cards because
i know how the trick works but before we
hurry over there
think with me about this mystery number
in here this is the number of red cards
we didn't count it when we performed the
trick but again if you're thoughtful
with me
you can work out how many red cards
there are without counting how many say
the ladder
there are four
how did we know that there were four you
go ahead
fantastic it's the pairing again isn't
it the nine cards here
correspond to or a symmetrical to the
nine cards here are you following
all right now we are so close
have a look at the screen really
carefully
how many red cards is not a trick
question how many red cards have i
currently accounted for
you can say it all aloud to me it's four
plus 17 which is 21 right but before we
even began the trick you know
that there are how many red cards in an
entire deck
there are 26 so 26 take away those 21
leaves you with
the five that i revealed at the end it
has to be there's no other way okay
now i did promise we're going to look at
this a second like there's going to be a
second method which will go a bit faster
you'll see why in a second but the
astute among you the observant will have
noticed there's a part of the trick that
i haven't explained yet
does anyone remember which part of trick
have i not talked about yet
i got annabelle to help me with it
remember
it was the
it was the swap wasn't it okay
now what i just explained to you what
we've all written down should tell you
that actually our swap that annabelle
helped us do
what difference does it make to the
numbers are the cards
it it doesn't make any difference right
i just wrote down all of those numbers
not talking about the swaps at all so
the swaps didn't muck around with it one
bit
so that leads to the next question which
is why not though like shouldn't they
have changed the situation somehow
do you have a theory there's a fixed
number of black and red cards and
because you really established that
there's
we we've subtracted some red and black
cards so the remaining at the top must
be always the same when you change it
you don't change anything other than the
fact you're just changing the general
number okay very good so if you didn't
quite follow that logic right it's about
the fact that we have 26 black cards and
26 red cards so let me see if i can
illustrate that same logic but just do
it um with the actual cards okay i'm
going to do this in super slow motion
just so that you can you tell me when to
stop okay
animal told us to do three cards right
but in mathematics when our problem is
complicated like a classic
problem-solving strategy is we look at a
simpler version of the complicated
problem and see if our understanding can
help us there okay so instead of
swapping three cards like we did the
first time let's just imagine swapping
one okay
now for the sake of illustration no it's
going to look silly but just follow me
okay
suppose that the one card that i chose
on both sides was by chance a red card
on both sides
and then i swapped them
not a rhetorical question
how have my numbers changed at this
point
they haven't right because one red just
became another red no big deal hopefully
you don't need me to actually do it to
prove that to do the same with the
blacks if i swapped a black card for a
black card again no change
what's really interesting is if the
colors are different watch really
closely okay i'm going to do it in slow
motion you tell me when to stop
here goes the black card i'm going to
swap it over to the other side
there are no longer five black cards
here there are now four
yeah
and now i'm going to finish the swap
here goes the red card
there are no longer
five red cards over here
there are four
and so as this reduces in one so does
the other one and in reverse if i'd gone
the other direction they'd go from five
five to
six six and that's why no matter how
many times we all do the trick we all
did it simultaneously we all end up with
the same
symmetry does that make sense
okay
let's finish this out because the topic
you're currently in is the reason why i
showed you this trick does anyone know
what topic you're in it starts with an a
it's algebra right
we're now going to do this not
numerically
we're going to do it algebraically okay
and even though you're like mr wu you
only have four minutes to do this it's
actually going to go much faster than
the other one right
algebra is just the kind of maths you do
with numbers that can change and that's
exactly the situation we're in right now
right every single one of you did the
trick slightly different to me and your
numbers modified as you went that's why
we have variables okay so instead of
writing for example that there's nine
black cards over here
they're black cards so
what pronumeral would you choose for
black cards
how about b for black okay very original
right so here are the black cards
now
let's rehearse that same logic that we
used when we were going through here
right if i wanted to i could go over
here and i could say oh these are the
red cards let's call it r
for red but hold on
it's actually not a separate independent
number it's related to b
you guys told me that there would be 17
over here
and you knew it from this nine how did
you do it again
you went 26 26 take away 9. now instead
of 9 i'm going to say
b
26 take away
b okay now remember how i did the trick
and i got up here sorry i'll just zoom
out so you can see i got five and then
five but
you didn't have to get five and five
some of you got seven and seven some
you've got ten and ten all different
kinds of combinations so this number can
also change so being that this special
important number can change let's call
it
x this is often the name we give to like
the special number right
now if this is x and then that's the
number of oopsy daisy sorry the number
of black cards over there
i then said
we could work out this number of red
cards in here and you all could tell me
that it was four but where did we get
four from
have a look carefully yeah
yeah nine take away five gave us four so
follow the logic down the bottom here
it's not nine it's
b
and instead of five it might not be five
in fact in your case it wasn't five so
it should be b take away
x okay let's jot that down
uh and these are red cards as well so
i'm going to write it in red b
take away x and at this point i said now
how many red cards have we accounted for
and you told me looking at the 4 and the
17 you said it was 21.
but now suddenly i've got all this to
contend with right like this is the
number i'll highlight it in green for
you this is the number of red cards that
i've counted the only problem is it can
change based on what b is and what x is
how did you use
26 and 21 don't move i promise i'll be
quick to work out five what did i do
26 take away
the 17 and the four right the 17
and the four do you agree with that
that gives you five okay
down here i'll zoom out so i hope you
can see it right
it's going to be 26
take away
26 take away b that's my 17
and i'm also going to have the
b
minus x that's the um that's the four do
you see that
that's the four right there okay
so watch what happens
isn't it lovely
there's the 26s they cancel
what happens to those b's
they cancel and then you've got watch it
carefully there's a negative there
and a negative there what do they do
they become positive and they leave you
with
that x just like you started
year eight i hope you learned something
of algebra's power out of that have a
fantastic afternoon